[Music]
hello weave injustice on psychology so
for those of you to join us from there
thank you I did promise and that games
of the week that I would go on more in
depth with the game theorist Jerry so
here's my promise
hopefully this end game makes sense and
when I looked at it and also with engine
it looked pretty interesting so without
further ado let's dive in hopefully
you've been following tata steel
tournament because most likely another
game of the week would be from there to
on Thursday and well it's very very
strong event world champion is playing
and so
this is the game between furious Joe
Giri
and he will finish it was white he ended
up winning this game sorry for the
spoilers and he he played a very nice
opening which you can see in last year
last week's game of the week but the end
game this is still some people would
argue this is still middle game since
there's still so many pieces on the
board but for me I see the same game so
lots of the coins were exchanged off the
port and pretty immediately you can see
that white seems to have better space
even though white is facing these two
bishops but like this pawn is under
attack so white is going for this pawn
why it could be attacking this pawn and
given the chance this ePHI pawn could
become a monster so it's black to move
first question how would you proceed
the way you can think about it is is
this pond worth trying to save the other
question is can you actually save it
because if it's white to move white will
most likely take here now it takes d4
and then your bishops look like shish
kebab
so can you actually try to save this why
these bishops
maybe we're not in Knight takes d5 maybe
even something like 91 which is safer
because let's say if it was white to
move Knight takes d4 black could try and
play Bishop III and attack your Knights
Knights so something like 91 would take
away that idea - I would keep defending
your knight and now the bishops are
again just keep up so those are things
that you should keep in mind this black
so it kind of feels like the move you
should be doing should be with one of
these bishops most likely
in the game they played Bishop c2
another came the another move that I
looked at was Bishop to e3 but I feel
like it's kind of the same ideas the
first you take on b7 and then you would
take on d4 and then after it's changed I
do feel like however this this type of
positions would be like more pleasant
for black rather than what happened in
the game because the King is kind of
stuck and black has a clear idea what to
do the bishop on d4 is a strong so
that's one line to look for with Bishop
to e3 to simply try to keep tabs on this
d4 pawn and you would be giving up the
common b7 now question what would you do
if rook d7 hand stroke e7 is not a good
move not the best move
how are you making your candidate moves
because 95 is something that's when you
think about it you immediately start
calculating so I feel like 95 it should
be one of your candidates
least of all but the best way to like
organize them is to think about first
checks which you don't really have here
then takes which you have a bunch of
takes like nine th for nine takes d4 and
then moves with threats which would be
probably 95 and I teach d6 stuff like
that that would be saving this night and
also attacking some piece of black so
that's usually how you would organize
your move orders well how to think about
what to think about first and I think
something like 94 you should consider
more seriously because again if you play
something like 96 there is this idea
with Bishop c2 now where do you put the
rook now these bishops are getting
unnecessarily too strong and now this
pawn is also could be a danger they say
it just feels like you're giving
opponent game compensation if you want
to call it and something like nine takes
d4 which eliminates that trait
immediately now you just have to
calculate does it work do you think it
works
yeah so if if it would go with Bishop T
4 rakat 5 this is actually better for
white whereas I think something like
rook t4 could be played and it kind of
transpose us to what we saw for rook t5
then withdrew p8 night for example d6 a5
then repeat you this looks more doable
I think whereas but compared to Bishop
takes d4 so that's something to consider
thinking about Bishop e3 however in the
game they went about it with Bishop c2
and Bishop c2 the idea is to simply
challenge your opponent what do you want
to do if you move the rook then this
pawn could start pushing so you kind of
have to take this pawn now you just have
to be careful and calculate if it works
and how well it works so now you're
attacking these two bishops so the next
move that black does should be about
these two bishops and you can't just do
simply a move like we should be 5
because of night take c2 so you gotta do
shish kebob again
and so now if white plays 9c2
even though it's not wrong Bishop takes
e5 it kind of like gives black more
space and your knight on c2 is kind of
ugly looking whereas what's happened in
the game with Knight goes to e6 now you
still are attacking this this guy your
knight here could have some better ideas
going to maybe c7 coming to the other
one County 26 just being more annoying
for your opponent and so yeah according
to computer
Bishop e4 is also something to consider
but rook e1 take take be 5595 this looks
winning but I feel like this might have
been slightly better for white at the
end just because White's still has
better space over here whereas in the
game instead of the show before they
played a Giri played Bishop g6 another
idea is that you are simply not letting
this rook f7 happen you don't really
have to worry about it so Bishop d6 I
feel like it's a very human rules Bishop
e4 would be a very feisty move I think
something to consider but why would you
give your opponent the chance to
actually can
try to do f7 etc so Bishop d6 in the
game they played rock f3 which black
could have thought about the ship c1 mmm
I was thinking maybe Knight f5 and then
when I looked it over with our beloved
engines it's actually slightly more
accurate just because in this situation
I say accurate but it just means that by
computer when both players do the best
of the best
it's kind of like equal going to a very
equivalent game but if you want to
create chances to give your opponent to
make mistakes then it shouldn't really
play something like Knight a5 take and
go into that end game even though it's
might be more accurate by engine it's
practically not the best that's one of
the differences between actually have
having to think like a human and play a
human rather than engine because
trajectory you kind of have to be black
you have to be in that very feisty
feisty move to play something like
Bishop c1 and after Bishop c1 as white
you shouldn't really give this pawn up
because it gives immediate past plant
creation so you could think about a move
like b3 or Ruby 3 and then you kind of
lose that nice flow of moves that you
had in center and kinks
now you're kind of moving it to the
queenside and especially since take
center is stored open and black has two
bishops it's not really as pleasant so
when I looked at this a little bit more
deeper after your Petrie repeat it does
not happen in the game I thought about
well can't I just take this but then
rook e8 intermediate moves and now if
you do something like Knight d4 this
Bishop f7 is kind of pinning you again
yeah it's some I want to call really
really interesting and games or if you
want to do some simply like 92 to kick
the bishop out and relocate your knight
see now black has a nice flow pushing
some ponds and black is controlling more
space so I feel like Bishop c1 would
have been a stronger approach to the
position rather than Bishop h6 that
happened in the game and so how do you
think why should approach
so what are the moves you're considering
six okay
not ever will have to do the whole lot
we can just put putting pressure simply
okay do you see any way that you can try
to improve your position as white okay
maybe I kind of do like rook f6 because
if you are putting more pressure and you
might have some ideas with maybe nice
goes to c7 and then they tried to bring
the other night jumping in so I do like
to work f6 idea yeah so yeah this was
something that I kind of considered but
the idea that they played in the game
was night at five dedeker I was thinking
about was if rook f6 and then the idea
could be to play Knight f5 so if like
Bishop f5 10 rocket six that's that's
something that I was playing with I'm
not good something like rook e8 be the
reason not to play Iraq f6
perhaps because if you move the knight
now the pawn is defenseless it I mean
black doesn't really have any immediate
truth but you also can't do pieces feel
a little tangled up so maybe that's why
not
so yeah Knight a5 it's also it's really
important as chess player to feel what
position needs I don't know how that
might sound feels kind of weird to say
something like that what your position
needs but also it's true like in this
position you can't really improve the
position as a whole with the pieces that
you have so you need to change something
and what
any change you can try and exchange this
night off with one of the bishops so
that's something that high level chess
player or higher level chess players
feel immediately by their instincts and
but it's like muscle memory for them
whereas for us we might have to actually
like convince ourselves that okay if I
play Knight a5 is it actually worth it
but my nice looks so strong in the
center but it's the matter of you can't
really improve the position anymore
that's that's the bottom line so that's
probably why 95 is the right move again
I thought about why not Bishop C one
because Bishop c1 was kind of strong in
the another line that we looked at and
Knight is for I feel like this is still
doable but I don't know to me it just
feels like this Bishop on h6 isn't doing
much so I really wanted to create some
opportunities and I do believe that
Ongina agreed with me computers also
thought somehow activating this Bishop
was a good idea it might it might not be
completely human moves to consider but I
mean technically you could try to push
the pawn but you could be faced with
Bishop c1 again attacking the knight and
then the the pawn is kind of hanging and
yeah so probably that's why Rick Petrie
is better
and just then going to this equal rock
hands game after the King moves
take-take-take or even to be more
accurate maybe King g8 so that the last
move wouldn't be with a check but again
it should be a draw and game regardless
so maybe something to remember if
something like this happens to you keep
your pieces active try to go for the at
least consider the super active moves we
should see Bishop c1 is the super active
move attacking b1 b2 and if you get your
Bishop in the diagonal you're also
taking a 5 and it's just more active to
put it simply so in the game Giri did
take five broken five and here I thought
about through t8 and then I I do think
it's kind of like a same idea of
transposition of what happened in the
game maybe slightly better this position
than what happened in the game let's
look at and what happened in the game
and then we'll jump back to this
position so in the game they followed up
at Bishop e3 and then rook e8 so they
like went to Drew Kent game with the
slightly worse pawns here that are nice
target practice whereas maybe after rook
e8 95
the idea is to jump to f7 now you gotta
defend that
and see if you would take it right now
as white white is cutting the king and
if something like h6 even rookies 5
still the king is cut the pawns are
under attack
something I've broken 5 should be good
too so yeah
that's why I can g8 now G for you need
to bring your king in papasan King comes
in
and now if black doesn't take the night
tonight you could start jumping around
and your next move you would take the
the tap on and your knight is also
active you have this past pawn in the
center so now in this truck endgame why
this is still slightly better but this
should still be a draw endgame because
let's get back to the game keep the note
on my because because in the game now in
the rock endgame this pawn is the
weakness and white will come and hunt
this pawn for example
see
yeah so the another line to look at it
was instead of rook e8 again we should
see one or maybe Bishop e6 to just keep
the king in the corner or even Bishop h6
to maybe see if your opponent wants to
repeat one thing about this three move
repetitions or three position
repetitions is it's also kind of
psychologically you're testing your
opponent's are you good to the draw and
then bike also gains a little bit of
time if you're in time travel but like
you would repeat it twice like here for
example after take take Bishop b3 track
f3 village six you're asking your
opponent so do you want to play we have
six so I can't play maybe we should be
treating again and then if we give three
now you would think about okay so not be
sugar six anymore if you take the
position the most you can get out of is
a draw why not but if not it's
psychologically questioning your
opponent and then if you don't do the
draw your opponent things oh is there
something in the position it's just this
little psychological warfare yeah so
we shall fight rook air-five Bishop e3
Luke f3 black
surprisingly did go for the parlance
game which is a slightly worse but it's
not losing pollen game was losing now in
this position black started pushing for
c5 sorry like should have started
pushing for c5 because if c5 you see
eventually both Kings are gonna come
close to this Eve I've pond and
eventually the game is going to go as we
will see that's the itch for pond will
fall and the e5 pawn will fall but the
problem is that it matters how advanced
one side spawns are because going to the
pond and game it's really that's the
determining factor so this is what
ideally should have happened and what is
it still slightly better but should be a
draw in game but in the game the black
played King g7 king of two against e5
should have been played but King g6 now
looking for attacking upon rookie four
is not necessarily like you're not going
to take this the next move this is
something that you're just putting
pressure and the pressure that you're
putting is gonna pay off because now
what should black to if black plays
something like h5 you bring the king the
King comes you just start slowly pushing
and again see if I was a good idea but
which surprisingly didn't happen in the
game at all yeah and like in this
situations how can white proceed if
white goes King III there's King fi you
take on s4 let's take with check if not
take on is for this is happening so if
you move it again
Ruki five again now if not King III how
can you bring your King to the other
side you see both sides are kind of
stuck it's a matter of who makes the
mistake first so that's the other idea
with c5 that's simply gaining more space
more Tempe so in the actual game they
didn't play h4 h5 they went with rook d7
and followed by King f3 logical move
right you're bringing your King to the
center you want to protect your pawn and
at the same time now if black pushes the
King if King f5 now I can take this if
King e4 whoops if King e5 rookie four if
not King if I have if rookie five you
can even consider take but I think you
should still go for the pawn and game
so after king of tree actually they did
play King at five but I was looking at a
five I think this was the last try that
black could do because a five you kind
of have to play like a tree if something
like B five now you push and black you
see is creating some chances to come and
fight the other way or even if not be
five something like Rookie of seven
check group back east seven its
questioning where wise king wants to go
if you start going to d4 you still get
checks I feel like I would have went
with something like King C tree but it
also feels like I'm leaving here a
little bit too empty but you see if you
go back to f3
again there's check you can't go to g4
really because you just move the pawns
and sorry you just move the rooks
and what are you trying to do you can't
as whites you can't really break through
you can't really penetrate this position
even if you try with something you care
for or even if you tear something like
rook a four it's still black it still
has a very good fight but in the game
the giri went for the pollens game which
is losing and this was very surprising
that he made that decision so in the
game she took the pawn and went for the
pennant game let's take a little bit
more time and look at the rook endgame
before we dive in the wide opponents
game is losing
for example if something like a five
again check King comes up this is again
winning you kept upon as white you want
the pawn on h4 you kept it you if I pawn
is a strong you rook is gonna come
jumping around a little your king will
come in you have a pass fun this is a
winning endgame if you try to take with
the rook it's again going to the pond
game if you try 757 again
oh this was actually pretty cool so Rock
t7 I thought it might work
the first glance cuz you want to give
some checks and create something here
but because of e-cigs it doesn't work if
Rukh tea tree you can just cooking a
fork you don't even need to do kinky for
a fruity for knocking here rook t1
turkey 5 so the idea was that in fruity
drinking air for who I can't take it 5
because this is Queen next move it was
actually pretty cool and see there are
some tactics and end games to even the
most boring European games
so anyways they followed up with just
going to the king versus opponent games
now in the first class do you think this
is draw its winning how's it going
I think
okay what are the factors you're
considering
kingside
drive a king
yeah that's pretty much the gist of it
yeah so now you remember when earlier I
was talking about the pond being on c5
so if the black managed to do that c5 b
5 it would have already been trying to
create some fights with the pass palms
or even if black tried to exchange off
some ponds with likes e5e5e5 just trying
to exchange off some ponds it would have
created more chance for not losing even
trying to win in this situation so they
happened to follow with king e4 I was
looking and I g4 is kind of more
accurate just because if something like
B a5 a4 if b5 oops
if b5 you bring the king and now the
king is going to the c4 c5 hole you see
this is I mean this endgame is winning
regardless but it just feels like if
this would have been a little slightly
more accurate well easier your
opponent's hands would be more tied but
where's it so money for life
I think
least of all black would put up a better
fight with playing c5 because see if you
play a 5 you will be faced with a 4 if
you play b5 we get B 4 so but if you
play c5 and then it's white to move
something like let's do if you had c5
and b5 yes black had a fair chance but
if just c5 I feel like it would still be
a better fight but I don't think it
would be enough the King is way too far
okay if c5 kingi for for example King e6
that's what we were considering G for
maybe b 5h 4
now this should this is not enough like
if the Kings were one one rank lower
yeah
then black was the one pushing yeah but
so the way they followed it in the game
was with king of four and king of six
but even if something like King d6 this
is again losing if ki whoops
if King e6 this is again same concept
you're trying to block off the Queen
side while you're going to create more
weakness in the Queen side and pushing
the king side and this is just all of
its is winning but King f6 still losing
because g4 the question is what do you
do with black if you start pushing I
just block it off and I create this past
pawn over here and it's also important
to have the past pounds farther in the
corners rather than in the center
because especially in content games
because then the King has to move travel
farther to eat them and then you just go
take care of the other pawns as happen
in the game yeah this is pretty
interesting endgame because white had
pressure pretty much all game but this
little ideas with like Bishop c1 trying
to activate it activate the bishop and
the position more for black seems to
actually work and I don't know how in
depth they thought about it in the game
but well gear is one of the best chess
players in the world so it was pretty
interesting to see that even he couldn't
find the most accurate news and that's
much pressure yeah let's move on to the
next time game
oh this was pretty cool
so in this endgame this is actually a
very famous endgame
first look black should be winning but
also its opposite colored bishops so
least of all is not going to be an easy
win
you had like black has to play it very
accurately so first of all white brings
the bishop back because if it was black
to move again probably g5 would be the
winning move so Bishop d2 you have to
push
Bishop c3 king of seven h4 King g1 for a
second it's looking like white actually
has things under control right because
the King can't really move this pawn
will fall and you can't start pushing
the pawns because well you can but you
can't push this pond whoops
kind of gave me that one but so remember
how we were talking about the King can't
go away because let's think about it I'm
going to flip the board okay it's black
so
ideally you want to have your king in
the center so it can support pushing
d-4d tree right that's ideal situation
but you can't do that because if you
play king d6 king c5 king c4 it takes
3-4 moves to be able to push this pawn
so the way that I believe she was
thinking about it was that he wants this
king here so badly that he is willing to
give up this bishop for pretty much
nothing now do you think is crazy or it
actually works
yeah that is a pretty valid guess but it
is a little bit crazy even the first
time I saw it I was like hmm I do I like
I know I want to move this bishop but
why can't I just do something like
Bishop g4 and then I realized oh if I do
like BCG for then even after King f5
kingi for still will have six but that I
kept thinking that shouldn't be working
that should still be winning enough or
at least of all I could maybe try to
like push these pawns first and then do
something crazy
but the from what I understood let's say
a tree King comes to f2 a to king can
just come to e3 and kind of like block
this idea or try to go to f3 and follow
with g4 and try to create a path bound
over here with like g4 than h5 so the
same idea that I've been telling myself
and everybody else not to give your
opponents chances to win not to give
them enough compensation and ideas and
fight and all of those stuff I feel like
Bishop history kind of follows that idea
that you are taking away your lack of
your opponent's last hope of winning or
even trying to hold the position because
take how would you approach
again I know it's a crazy move I'm not
saying everybody sees it
yeah
mm-hmm
uh-huh
probably have to bring out the King
right
now go to e4 is it about time
yeah that's something that you would
also like worry about because if the
pondrá falls then how can you hold the
position yep the king is way too far now
how can this stop probably Bishop to e7
is the only way now what
you can't touch this one
it should you bring the king or the pawn
okay so everybody's thinking
if King comes the d3 your next wave is
king c2 most likely and then you push
the pawn right seems like an easy win
let's think about what if d3 these are
probably a bishop before or King e1 and
now there could even be some checks you
take this pawn you can't get close
enough to stop this pawn even though
these three seems like a more natural
move King d3 is the winning move is the
more accurate move you just simply
you're attacking the bishop you're not
giving your opponent chances to bring
the king closer you're kind of cutting
the king with your king now you go for
making a queen that way and even if
something like kinky to what do you do
yeah that should be that should be
winning and afraid you're coming in with
check even if something like Bishop
before check King II one you can push
this one or you can even push this one
win right yeah hold on
nope see these are the little blunders
that you do so first and if take now you
push yeah it's it's also very common
that you have a winning position and you
have to find the most accurate moves and
you don't or you just play it too fast
and kind of mess it up so yeah this was
actually very very interesting endgame
I've actually never had such an insane
endgame but this was pretty interesting
just because okay if there was a pawn on
h3 you would kind of consider taking
more just because that's what pieced up
the first thing you see okay my bishop
is kind of attacking that part so
something to consider Oh what if I take
it and bring in my king but the pawn on
h4 it's also a little weird to just
think about putting a bishop on each
tree also if the opponent doesn't take
it and bring out the king I'm pretty
sure you could just bring in the king or
even take it wait no if you take it now
bring in the King maybe can get four
kind of blocks everything up three
blocks this King coming in
so what do you think king up to what
should black dude
yeah keep up with the plan if something
like King III say that take the pawn and
say thank you can you have three
probably same take the pawn and thank
your opponents by meeting him and yeah
so stick to the plan make your king
better keep pushing forward the chance
to push the pawns yeah this was pretty
pretty intense endgame all right let's
look at another one
oh this was pretty sad all right I'm
ready to face my sadness all right
so this game I was black I I had a
pretty tough opening in the game and I
was pretty happy to enter did the end
game and I thought that this should be
draw this should be hold a bull and I
kind of messed it up so what do you
think I should do this is the position
so white played rook c5 in this position
and how do you think black should
approach
it's a rupee one yasuno drizzle enough
or rook b1 something like b5 what did
you know know P - yeah you wanna try and
cut the king
yeah I agree with that I think I did
play rook a to to try and cut the king
and she played f4 what do you think is
the most logical move here for black
yeah surprisingly I didn't do it I keep
telling myself and everybody tried to
keep your opponent's pieces all tangled
up don't make it easy for the opponent
and I forgot my own advice in time
trouble
hey anyways so yeah yeah I think that's
the way I went about it and it didn't it
got kind of ugly and yeah I do think G 4
is the way to go because even if
something like rook d5 you should simply
be able to just put the rook here and
just play something like king g6 and
you're asking your opponent okay what do
you want to do or even if even you could
try to do something like rook p1 cutting
the king completely and now what do you
want to do probably with what probably
whites will try to push over here to
create something along these sides but
without the without the king being
active and completely cut off White's
position students be able to improve to
a winning extent I mean what is it still
better but the King can't come in simply
so I forgot my own advice ha
but so anyways take take something like
a tree I still wanted to go for cutting
the king but it kind of didn't pay off
because simply take take and there's
this g3 king each tree King g4 oops yeah
I ended up losing the game yeah it
wasn't my finest moment so remember
always cut the king
don't let the king come in especially in
in games especially in routine games the
more passive your opponent's king the
better chances you have of activating
your own pieces let's do one more
this was pretty fun all right
it's black to move this should be a fun
puzzle how do you win let's finish off
on a good note oh it's a puzzle
that I know
one little tip usually with nights and
games it helps a lot if you actually
picture what you want what you're trying
to get out like where where you want to
have your nights and then try to just
find the right pathway to get there yep
that is true
today
ah
maybe that also wins but you have you
have a more strong approach let's think
about it where is the wise king trying
to run off yeah so block that
yeah that is one way but that's also a
correct way yes that is true
so how do you picture this the final
position how do you picture it don't
think about the pond the white pond just
think about your two nights where do you
want them to be yes exactly yeah
yeah yes so you have a clear idea that
you have to give a check on a tree to
kick the king to go to a-1 king is not
willingly gonna go there so
Knight d3 or the other night to d3
pushing the pawn you're not going to
take it because if you take it yeah it's
already a draw
how are you gonna try and push the king
to go to kink to corner
okay
okay
yes
yeah
yeah
yeah perfect there are other ways to
solve this the Knights could be
positioned differently but the gist of
it is that you block in the initial
position you block the King trying to
run away to see one with night 82 or 93
either one of them should work black
white has to start pushing upon so now
you create a check to push the King to
go to any one and then you bring out the
night to finish it off yeah good job you
managed to finish it off pretty nice
well I hope you enjoyed it we have some
interesting game games it was more
theoretical than last week that last
week was all crazy puzzles and hopefully
we'll see you on Thursday for my choice
and the game of the week thank you
you
[Music]